after you have put so many
terrible policies in place that have
disrupted the development of young
people
to then
say ah anything the young person says or
feels is the final truth and the final
arbiter of how it is that the rest of us
are going to interact with them
is a advocation of responsibility at
every every every level so we're doing
that with regard to
kids and and teenagers and young people
who have been just
emotionally and psychologically and in
many cases otherwise as well
extraordinarily damaged by two years of
this madness and who are now like well i
gotta keep wearing it like it's the only
it's like it's the consistency right
like whatever it is whatever story it is
they tell themselves it doesn't matter
it is the job of the adults to say
actually honey
no it's it's it's time for that to go
because you don't need it you haven't
needed it and it's bad for you same
thing with regard to children who wake
up one day you know on tuesday they
decide they're a dinosaur and on
wednesday they they decide their
spider-man and on thursday they decided
that they're the sex they are not
and
no one tries to get them surgery to turn
into a dinosaur
or
you know decides to wrap them in spider
silk but
somehow
because
there is
there are very very rare
disorders
uh in which
trans seems to be the best way to
proceed with life
the much the
majority of people who especially as
children who are waking up going
you're actually a boy i'm a girl now or
vice versa um
when parents
and us and health
health professionals
say oh yeah
no we're not gonna of course he's not a
dinosaur of course he's not spider-man
but he is a girl because he said he was
and because he said he was a girl
we are going to stop you know stop
puberty from progressing and then once
we've done that for a while we are going
to start giving cross-sex hormones and
then i mean i guess if it's a boy um
claiming to be a girl the surgical
interventions don't happen as as a
teenager thank god but um the girls who
decide to be boys they're doing what
they're calling top surgery on kids
and you never get that functionality
back
nor do you get the functionality back
associated with cross-sex hormones or
with puberty blockers you just don't
why would we ever
take the word
of a child or a teenager as
the reality that everything must follow
this is what childhood is this is not
the moment at which they have everything
figured out everyone who's been a child
or a teenager knows this but especially
in an environment in which we have so
disordered their development in the case
of trans
through um through social media through
screens through um you know
hormonal
things in the water of various sorts
through plastics and and such
um and uh and through basically
woke crazy gender ideology in schools
and with regard to covid with regard to
everything we've just talked about
you've disordered the development of
children and now you're going to take
what they claim as the god's honest
truth and we need to change what we do
to deal to accommodate their desires and
fears no it's our job to do the opposite
it's our job to not accommodate their
fears and to help them
undo some of the damage that we have
done to them yes it's effectively a
postmodern mask mandate
yeah right their basic point is look
your lived experience if you think that
this does control the virus then it does
keep wearing it and if you think it
doesn't then you're free to stop and
it's like no no
that is not how this works there's it
either is an effective measure in which
case why are you
eliminating it or it isn't an effective
measure in which case
everybody needs to take those things off
immediately and
abdicating responsibility like this is
uh is absurd
[Music]
you